start Oh first of all a everyone its
team honcho from glider I'm here with
the cat everyone behind Brittany runs a
marathon here at Sundance before we get
started when he gave a huge shout out to
Kia Telluride they're a great sponsor
and they make this interview happen and
all of our interviews happen so big
thank you to Kia so first of all I think
there's a party going on next year right
[Laughter]
I'm we're at Sundance and this is just
such a celebration of film here I'm
definitely curious what was it like for
you finding out that your film got in
mind blowing I heard that someone from
Sundance was looking for my phone number
and I was about to walk out the door and
I ran to my desk and I sat there and
just looked at my desk like trying not
to freak out for twenty minutes and then
they called and it was it was crazy
wait I'm sorry you're saying that you
were freaking out about not hearing no I
heard that they were making phone calls
and then I heard someone just called an
ask for your phone number yes and I rent
my my dog was leashed up I just drew
that leash on the ground and ran to my
desk
the dogs fine and just waited and it was
it was amazing it was a dream come true
I've heard from some people they have to
hold the secret for a long time when did
you find out you got in like two weeks
two and a half weeks before the
announcement so it was good yeah so it
was a long time and and I did my best
and everyone knew except for you know so
listen I hate doing the generic thing
but everyone watching Oh almost everyone
watching will not have seen the movie
yet so can you talk a little bit about
the movie and also for all of you who
you play in the film
yeah the movies about it's inspired by
my real-life best friend it's about a
woman in her late 20s whose life is not
going the way she wants it to and she
decides to make a change and she doesn't
really know much more than that she has
to make a change and she runs one block
the next day too and her life
transforms as a result her habits
transform as a result we see that
transformation for what's good about it
and what's bad about it and it's it's a
heartfelt inspirational story and I'm
hoping other people get inspired by it
this cast is brilliant and I'm so lucky
to have had all of them I can't believe
it
and do you guys want to say what you do
in the film I play Brittany thank you
it's Britney [ __ ]
basically the story is about and it was
very inspirational and I read it and I
was like please let me play this but
also I'm terrified and Paul and I just
got on the same page about it and really
cared about her and protected her
throughout and so yeah so I'm playing
the title character and these wonderful
[Music]
I play I like to describe my characters
like Brittany's big brother slash kind
of like father figure in a way I'm
married to Brittany's sister and I just
like having and me and Paul talked about
this the movie has so much heart and I
was excited to play a character that has
his heart and you know he's able to keep
it 100 with her and this has been one of
my fun like I feel like every roll of
plate I've taken from stuff and I
believe this particular film and we're
talking more about it but you end up you
just learn more about yourself and you
know when you're trying to better
yourself things you want to let go and
how hard that is and but it was really
cool to play like I don't know I guess I
want to be I'm a dad in real life I was
like I like being a dad
coude like a cool big brother dad and
you don't show a lot of those templates
characters those guys who do take on
those roles especially if they've they
married into the family and the family
has embraced him and he took on the role
as if this is his sister so it's what
i'm saying i'm terrible.i he described
his took it i want to start saying
scenes I play yes and I I I'm a neighbor
of Brittany and she's I think Brittany
thinks she's got kind of a semi large
stick up her ass and and then lo and
behold as we may discover she may or may
not be one of Brittany's greatest
support systems that takes place of old
support systems we'll see I play
Brittany's new friend SEF and to become
friends because they're the two slowest
runners at least for me Julianne
actually ran quite a bit for the film
and became quite a runner I I didn't
tell viola but as so anytime movie you
see just running and we're tired I'm I'm
tired it's it's so real hmm first of all
kiya thank you love your furniture he's
great
it's a car that makes meatballs now
they're thinking like we should make
meatballs
I play Jaron and he's sort of like a
man-child he's somebody who's lived off
of potential for a long time and now the
potentials run out and he's kind of just
coasting through life and meets Brittany
and they affect each other and that's
all Paul has allowed me to say and it's
great it was amazing playing opposite
Gillian she's incredible you are
for anyone who's gonna see this movie
everyone's gonna know about this in two
days but you are a leading woman through
and through lead actor like you carry
this movie such a pleasure to watch you
in it and to be with you on screen and I
wish I could have acted with the other
people here but my experience what Paul
separated us all my contract we made
sure that I couldn't it's such a
pleasure I can't wait for people to see
her in this role I'm always curious
about the the editing room because
that's ultimately the final rewrite so
what was it like getting all the footage
in the editing room what you learn from
your first cut and you know maybe from
early screenings that's a really good
question I you know I come from theater
and in theater you do rehearsal for
weeks and then you you know you you
finish it up this is the opposite you go
in there you you work with everybody to
find the heart and soul of what you're
doing the humanity and the heartbeat of
the story and you you basically set
yourself up so that you can go in the
Edit room and we're hearse with the
actors from the footage you have and you
craft the scene around that and these
brilliant actors like they're so they're
all so good in it they're all doing
things you've never seen them do before
gave so much nuance and pathos and what
they were doing that there were endless
versions of scenes to make because every
that there wasn't we weren't cutting
around anything we were we were trying
to figure out which goal to keep and
you know in the Edit I what we were able
to do is keep the script intact I you
know I restructured a little bit but
then go deeper just based on what each
of these actors brought to the
characters and and find the nuance or
the reactions that I wasn't expecting
when I wrote it or even on set that I
noticed that we then saw in the Edit
room
I'm curious oftentimes for actors and
for everyone when you're making a movie
you're reading the script and you see oh
that that seems gonna be a challenge to
shoot or I'm a little nervous about that
scene for whatever reason for each of
you was there was there what scene maybe
made you the most nervous before filming
because if you if you can share it well
real quick and this is to this question
is an eye and I just want to make sure I
get this out the way Paul do I like
directors and writers that are tied into
what they're doing so even if I'm not
sure if I what I did what they're saying
when you come you know heels cut and you
see him have tears in his eyes or be
very invested into your performance like
I applaud you for that marrow but you
never stop doing that because it makes
the actors without you having to tell me
just makes me happy that you care about
the material and what we're doing our
performances and like you as tied it
like I literacy Paul but I appreciated
that you know as an actor and you don't
lose that that's why it's interesting
that you almost forget this this was
your first time directing man but like
yo don't lose that cuz I you you your
actors are really be attached to and
want to do their best for you when you
do they know you're attached to it later
yeah I will add on to that that he's so
passionate and driven and there wasn't a
single thing I had a question about that
he was like let me think about that like
you would thought about every possible
angle of this for all of our characters
and and part of that is being the writer
of the film but I feel beyond that they
you would have been invested if it
wasn't even your your film that you
wrote and that was beautiful and I mean
was it a 5 or 20 you handed them
I'm getting a Kia yeah I'm getting both
furniture that makes this they'll be had
a best car seats in the world the best
thing about working with Kia you're
missing one wheel and you had to come
back to the store was it like this on
set like there was this there was an
instant it was it was a labor of love
for everyone so we were doing our best
to support whatever mood we needed that
day and there's a lot of comedy in it
but it's also a dramatic story I mean
we're really telling a human story about
this woman who doesn't necessarily get
this treatment often so we wanted to
treat everything with respect there's
some intense shooting days there in some
intense scenes and but you know we did
we did enjoy each other I will say I
want to give a shout out to our crew too
because this was my first drama dramedy
and a lot of scenes were very emotional
and we would be walking around and I'm
just pacing in rooms just crying just
trying to stay in a state of mind and
they were just so respectful and like
some of them would just like come up and
be like and just like you know keep
doing their jobs but like encouraging
you in the littlest ways and you just
felt taken care of throughout and I I
think a lot of that comes from you too I
think you were very communicative of
like what kind of set we wanted to have
but it was beautiful because we had that
with the cast and the crew and if I can
just say working with Jillian like she's
you know I know there's a comedian and
when we do bits and jokes and everything
like that you know it's a fun way to
sort of cover up all our feelings and
this movie there's no room for that she
just laid bare and raw and it really set
the tone for all the rest of us to kind
of cut the cut the ha ha and just work
and be as and just meet her on there or
at least try our best to meet her there
because she was so deep in the movie
happens within the heart and soul of
Brittney and so that happens within the
heart and soul of Jillian so what
Jillian laid herself she was completely
vulnerable during this process in a way
that was very inspiring to watch and
admirable and also you know scary it was
scary there were certain scenes were
like we would end and I just want to
check in on everybody because some of
them were some of the scenes were very
hard mentally and emotionally and then
some physically of course with the theme
of the movie but yeah it was really
intense but it was nice to be able to
check in with everyone and just make
sure like everyone felt good and felt
like they got what they needed as an
actor but then also as a human being
because we were dealing with a lot of
raw emotions yeah sensitive stuff that
we needed to some of us I mean I learned
a lot about how to evolve as a sensitive
human on this process because it needed
it that energy comes from the top down
you know from the people that Paul chose
to be in the cast and the people he
chosen the crew I mean is like it's the
only time that trickled down economics
works is in this kind of situation and
it just made any time even if a scene
was difficult you know with with actors
like this all you have to do is is look
at them and respond in your jobs done
and that doesn't happen a lot completely
on that note I want to say once again
thank you so much for coming into the
studio a huge thank you to Ikea Kia and
for sponsoring specifically Kia
Telluride
right but no but but for real thank you
so much for coming in and I hope it's a
huge hit at Sundance thank you you know
what I mean thank you thank you so much
you